Ngoài Mì sau tháng 12 năm 2018, công an tính lâm động viện thảnh khám nghiệp hiện chương.
Đưa tra làm só vụ sợ bơ tương tại Canting Trung Tâm đào tạo và sách hệ g lại xe năm cao win
xác hư dút tính lâm động khiến một học viên từ vòng. Ná nhân được sất định là ông DVK,
sinh nămu nghìn chiến trăm bệ Mì sau, buồ sả ỡ ai về lời, tính đắc lắc, học viên của Trung Tâm dở dụng miệng nghiệp cao win.
Thông tin bà đầu, sáng cùng ngày trong nước trở đến lời sách hạnh, một nhóm học viên năm vóng nghĩ hơi tại khu vực Canting của Trung Tâm.
Nhiều chiếc khoảng được móc và bở tương gạc cao khoảng 1 mệt, bở tương ngày đồ sập,
cao theo các mạng bế tông khiến nhiều học viên đã xuống. Họ qua, 2 học viên bị bở tương và bế tông đại chúng,
đứa đưa đi cấp thứ ngày sau đó. Tuy nhiên, gió bế tương quán nặng, ông ca đá khu quà khòa,
một số hục viên khác mi thương nhẹ. Đừng biết trong 2 ngày 15 vàng em bị sảo tháng 12 năm 2020,
phòng cảnh sách sợ thông công an tính lâm đồng tổ chức kỳ sách hệ g lại xe tại Trung Tâm đào tạo.
Bà sách hệ g lại xe năm cao viên cho phuyên của Trung Tâm giáo giúp miếp đắt nông và Trung Tâm giáo giúp miếp cao viên.